-I am here with John Cena
and he and I...
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
...are getting ready to go
head-to-head --
or face-to-face --
in a game of "Facebreakers."
-Yeah, that's right.
-Now, here's how it works.
We're going to take turns
throwing footballs
at that wall of glass
with our faces on it.
The first person to break all
of their opponent's faces wins.
[ Laughter ]
There's John's face.
-Yep.
-And there is my face,
right there.
[ Laughter ]
Couldn't we have gotten
a better face for my face?
[ Laughter ]
-It looks good.
-It looks like I was wearing
like sunglasses
or like a suntanning --
Why do I have lines in my hair?
-Oh, I just noticed that.
-It's every man for himself.
John, are you ready to start
breaking face?
-I'm not, but let's go.
-Alright, you are my guest,
so you will go first.
Please, John Cena.
-Alright, let's do this.
Alright.
Do we have to stand
on the shamrock?
-Yeah, yeah, that's a shamrock
-Yes, okay.
-for good luck.
[ The Roots playing funk ]
[ Audience ohs ]
-Got a little too excited!
-Come on!
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience ohs ]
♪♪
-Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
We got this.
Alright, let me show you
how it's done.
-We're building the suspense.
-Go back and then go forward.
Wham! Boom!
[ Rimshot ]
-Ooh!
-What's up?!
[ Cheering and applause ]
What's up?!
That's one down.
♪♪
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Rimshot ]
-[ Announcer voice ]
With the grace
of a beardless Dan Fouts.
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That was good.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I told you we were
building suspense!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Dude.
[ Rimshot ]
-Ohhh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This is so exciting.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You bastard!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright!
Yeah, I got home field.
♪♪
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Dude, you got a good arm.
That was good follow through
on that one.
-Coach Howell could be proud.
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Dude.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-It's close. It's close.
-This is a close game.
This is a close game.
I love this.
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I don't like you.
[ Rimshot ]
-Dude.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Dude, what is going on?
-I don't know!
-This is amazing.
I should try out for the NFL.
[ Laughter ]
This is the best I've ever
done in my life.
♪♪
-[ Announcer voice ]
Wearing the colors
of Ken Stabler,
he tries for the long pass.
I got to throw it
a little touch.
[ Audience ohs ]
Oh!
♪♪
[ Audience ohs ]
-Ooh!
-Alright.
I got to hit the high one.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Alright, I got to get two.
Oof, oof, oof, oof,
oof, oof, oof.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Ohhh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering intensifies ]
♪♪
-I would like
to offer you a draw.
Audience:
No!
-No way!
-Okay, fine!
-No way! Good luck!
-Fine, that's fine.
You don't want the draw?
-Good luck!
I don't want the draw!
-Then fine!
-Let's go!
-Eat this, Fallon!
[ Drumroll ]
[ Audience ohs ]
-You're going down, buddy!
-Should we go with the draw?!
-No!
We got to --
Are we out of footballs?
-Throw the buckets.
[ Laughter ]
-Fine.
We throw the buckets.
-Yeah, throw the buckets.
-Do I go first?
-Yeah, I'll go --
-Should we simultaneously throw?
-Simultaneously throw.
Ready?
-Alright.
-Throw the bucket.
-On 3?
-1...
-Is it 1, 2, 3, throw?
-1, 2, 3, throw.
-Yep.
-[Both] 1, 2, 3.
[ Thudding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-That's how you build suspense!
[ Laughing ] That's how
you build suspense.
-[ Laughing ]
That was the way to do it,
right there.
John Cena!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
That's the champion.
That's the champ, right there.
"Vacation Friends"
is streaming on Hulu now.